we know that there is a lot of energy
it's very exciting but but the energy is
because of the lockdowns it's because of
the schools being shut down I mean you
heard in the debate she came out and she
said our schools were only locked down
for three months which is a total lie
even even just today at this rally we
had a young man who he must be in high
school probably about 16 17 years old
and he said I listened to her say that I
was out of school for a year and a half
in Ann Arbor this is when you have the
students who are the ones that are
standing up
and seeing that these politicians are
being dishonest I think that's a really
interesting turn because now politicians
have to realize that they're not just
being watched by adults that what
they're doing is being watched by kids
because kids have more access to the
news and politics than they ever have
before and so when children are watching
you and they hear you say something
dishonest I mean those those are the
folks that are going to call you out
every time right the kids turn around
and they say oh this the governor's
lying
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the Republican nominee for governor of
the great state of Michigan Tudor Dixon
tutor welcome to the Reuben report
so thank you for having me
well I'm very happy to have you on I
have to get two things off my chest
before we start number one I don't like
Gretchen Whitmer very much and I've made
a lot of fun of her in the last two
years or so and then number two I did
not know much about you until about two
weeks ago after uh once I watched you in
the debate and I was super impressed so
for the for the people that don't know
too much of you about you outside of
Michigan uh can we do a little a little
Tudor Dixon 101 first yes absolutely so
a little bit about me I am a mom of four
daughters so I have kids that went
through the whole school pandemic crisis
and was walking alongside the other
parents during that time but I think
something that most people don't know
about me is that I'm a businesswoman I
come from the steel manufacturing world
my family had a steel foundry in
Michigan and so I worked on the shop
floor for many years went from the steel
casting industry into the forging
industry so I had worked in heavy
equipment mining railroad military
equipment and then with the automotive
industry so I learned our Michigan
automotive industry but then about five
years ago I had a friend come to me and
say I'm not sure if you know what's
happening in our schools and at that
time the concern was just this
anti-American message I mean you know
you talk about it all the time
and kind of the indoctrination that was
happening in schools so we created a
media company at that time to counteract
CNN 10 that's in our middle and high
schools and we started that that
expanded into working on political
campaigns and then working on a a
conservative conservative Network and
through that we said you know what
grutch we started going through the
pandemic watching what Gretchen Whitmer
was doing and said who's going to take
this woman out of office we've got to
take our state back and that was kind of
our We the People moment when I said
well let's do this and see what it takes
and so far it's been an interesting ride
but we are really we feel the support of
the people in the state of Michigan the
campaign is really thriving the momentum
is there we just had a rally and I think
about five people came up to me and said
I've never attended a political rally
before but I am just so jazzed up for
this election so we feel the momentum on
the ground and it's really exciting I
think my business background was kind of
unexpected from Gretchen Whitmer she saw
me as more of a political commentator
and I guess thought that potentially I
wouldn't be able to go toe-to-toe with
her when it comes to the debate and
understand the the private sector the
way I do and I think that was unexpected
for her and I feel like we maybe had her
on her heels a bit Yeah well I love the
story there because I think this is the
theme right now with this new crop of
politicians people that didn't really
want to be Paul politicians people that
were kind of doing other things
productive members of society had
families and then ultimately reality or
I suppose Democrat or Progressive
reality hit them in the face and then
you felt like you had to get involved so
uh you're on the you're on the campaign
bus right now it looks like the polls
are basically neck and neck like I take
it you're feeling pretty good
yeah absolutely right now we're we are
tied in the polls we feel very good we
feel like we have a lot of good momentum
like I said on the ground but even from
what we're hearing from the little the
the that we can hear from the media in
locally we're being told that we're not
seeing the crowds at the Whitmer events
that we're seeing at the Dixon events so
we know that there is a lot of energy
it's very exciting but but the energy is
because of the lockdowns it's because of
the schools being shut down I mean you
heard in the debate she came out and she
said our schools were only locked down
for three months which is a total lie
even even just today at this rally we
had a young man who he must be in high
school probably about 16 17 years old
and he said I listened to her say that I
was out of school for a year and a half
in Ann Arbor this is when you have the
students who are the ones that are
standing up
and seeing that these politicians are
being dishonest I think that's a really
interesting turn because now politicians
have to realize that they're not just
being watched by adults that what
they're doing is being watched by kids
because kids have more access to the
news and politics than they ever have
before and so when children are watching
you and they hear you say something
dishonest I mean those those are the
folks that are going to call you out
every time right the kids turn around
and they say oh this the governor's
lying and that's what so many parents
have come to me when I said you know I
just heard an audible gasp across
Michigan when you when you lied about
the schools being shut down for three
months to me and said that was the thing
it was our kids in this in the family
room sitting with us that had the
audible gasp and said no that's not true
we were out for much longer than that
this is very interesting to see this the
Democrat Party kind of
trying to they're flailing they're
trying to figure out exactly who their
base is and they seem to have lost their
base yeah it was really a wild moment
because she said it you immediately
called her out on it I'm pretty sure I
just heard an audible gasp around town
when Gretchen Whitmer said that kids
were out of school for three months
perhaps she wasn't paying attention to
what was actually happening even we even
had schools that were closed this year
this is shocking to me that she thinks
that schools were only closed for three
months or maybe she thinks she can
convince you that schools were only
closed for three months but you know
better because your students are the
ones that are desperately behind and the
test scores show that she's being
dishonest about this she's being
dishonest about even trying to get into
these schools to get these schools back
on track clearly the audience didn't buy
it anyone that's paying any attention
didn't buy it uh I don't know if you
know this but in the in the midst of all
that I lived in California at the time
I'm in Florida now but even in Crazy
Cali with our lockdowns I was sending
seeds to people in Michigan because if
you remember she didn't want people to
Garden in their own backyard yards so I
was literally sending seeds to people in
Detroit and all over Michigan for that
but what do you make of that that
concept that she can bold face lie like
that I mean when you shake her hand did
you shake her hand after like yeah do
you say to her hate lady the cameras
aren't on like how do you do it how do
you do it she can do it because the
media comes to her rescue every time
they say I mean well can we technically
say that the schools were only out for
three months we I mean and I just
blasted this guy the other day no you
cannot because the schools were out for
a year and a half what are you talking
about how could you possibly hold the
water for this politician but they are
definitely in full-blown defense of her
but what you said about the Seas it's
very interesting because I think a lot
of people don't understand what happened
in the state of Michigan she did we
actually had sections of our grocery
stores that had police tape around them
saying you can't go into this section
and buy this I had a woman yesterday who
said I have a greenhouse we were stopped
from having curbside service for Easter
lilies but she said I said you know I
had a guy in Grand Rapids say the same
thing but down the street they can sell
marijuana curbside she said yeah I think
it's the same growing process but we
were stopped and we actually had they
actually had notices on their door that
they would be sent to jail that's how
Gretchen Whitmer operated and another
guy just stopped me and this was really
interesting he said don't ever forget he
said I'm a surgeon and don't ever forget
that every surgery was considered an
elective surgery we were shut down from
knee Replacements from broken ankles
everything was shut down but the
abortion clinics were open so it was
interesting how that worked it's
interesting because there's a Confluence
of the the covid stuff and then what you
started with which was you know the
parental rights sort of thing are you
finding that there's a whole bunch of
new people that would not traditionally
be Republicans because that seems to be
the thing that's happening all over the
country look you're going to have your
base on either side but there is this
huge wave of I would say mugged liberals
who are just like enough of this
so much so and I brought this up in the
debate too because we have a community
in Michigan Dearborn Michigan that has a
strong Democrat base this is a largely
Muslim Community and when I was at one
of our rallies I had a father come to
the rally from Dearborn and he said I
just wanted to we we do these Town Halls
where we'll let people ask us anything
and so he said I just want to make a
comment I recently went to my elected
officials in the Democrat Party and I
said I don't like this content that's in
our schools and he said I was called a
racist and a bigot and he said that I
had been running for a position I had
been running for elected position as a
Democrat and he said I won't vote
Democrat this year and I'm going to tell
everybody in my community that they
should not vote Democrat because the
Democrats will not protect our kids from
this stuff and I told this story at the
debate and Stephen Colbert picked it up
and said this never happened all the
story of this man that never existed
well the man was so mad and I think this
is what we're going to start seeing
folks that have true concerns that your
elected officials should stand up for
that are being ignored because they're
not pushing the right propaganda and he
stood up and he said he got really mad
and he said no when he went to the local
news and he said you know I'm being made
fun of on Stephen Colbert and I give the
local news credit for actually running
historians saying no he actually did
stand up at her rally and say this and
that has sort of also put the whole
Democrat Party on their knees because or
on their heels because they're going uh
they should be on their knees maybe at
this point
um on their heels saying shoot what are
we going to do now that this guy came
forward and said this really is the
truth and the Democrats aren't listening
to what the real issues are but isn't
that the problem across the country
they're telling us that the issues we
should have are not the issues we do
have I mean energy Independence oh no no
don't worry about that the Border no no
no don't worry about that focus on these
other things no the people know what to
worry about right and then of course it
turned out that in Dearborn Michigan all
of these Muslim parents were at the
school board meetings and some videos
did actually really go viral of them
saying hey enough of this indoctrination
so Colbert I always say he's just part
of the machine he just will say whatever
whatever they put out there but speaking
of the media there was a really nice
moment after your debate where you
basically just stood there you were
surrounded by probably I don't know 30
reporters and they just all have the mic
in your face and you just like one at a
time answering every single question and
the whole time I was watching it we
played some of it I was thinking is
there any chance Whitmer did anything
like that no you know she was over there
but she actually brought in a bunch of
elected officials to stand with her and
help her answer the questions so I don't
know exactly what her media scrum looked
like but I know they're certainly much
harder on me they want to they want to
push this narrative they want to help
her out to say gosh this side their
conspiracy theorist I'm like this is
hilarious that they're concerned about
the fact that we go back and say well in
the state of Michigan Jocelyn Benson
broke a few of the rules our secretary
of state broke a few of the rules
without talking to the legislature at
judge actually came out and said that
some of the things she did in the
election were unlawful and so we of
course get hit with that well you
believe that this election was unlawful
no a judge believes that this election
was unlawful it's not me but they're
they're like oh we've got to come up
with something to make these people
scary and have them vote against them
the media is literally helping them to
try to create a narrative that does not
exist and so we know when we go into
those media scrums that it's going to be
a battle and we're just going to knock
each question out make sure that we get
the questions done and move on do you
get invites for the from mainstream like
on CNN or MSNBC or any of that stuff
uh we actually I will say that um oh
maybe not I can't remember if it was CNN
or not but you know in those cases I
don't think that we're gonna be asked
the the fair or the nice questions at
this point I 100 know that these media
Outlets are there to try to get
Democrats elected I mean we're at the
point now where we see it they're
running stories straight out of the
opposition research book like they've
gotten down to the bottom and they
haven't been able to knock out
Republicans so they're putting they're
going to the news and could you run this
story we think there might be some
accuracy to it I mean these are just you
know they get a wild hair and they try
to run with it it's not even true is
there is there any coordination between
you and some of the other Republican
candidates that are picking up steam
right now I mean if you see what's going
on in New York Lee zeldin who nobody I
mean basically nobody knew of outside of
a small District in New York until about
a month ago uh you know Cary lake is
seems to be on fire now in Arizona are
you guys coordinating in any way on
message Jing or anything or you all just
kind of doing your own thing yeah
doing our own thing but I Carrie Lake
and I have spoken several times
obviously our states are all a little
bit different Michigan is definitely a
state where we are very concerned about
school right now the school system has
been in a steady decline now that we've
gotten through covid and there has been
no assistance no tutoring program in
place the schools are now in the bottom
10 in the nation so for us it's really
important to talk to parents about
getting schools back on track getting
our kids back on track getting the
tutoring that we need in the classrooms
but then overall in general making sure
parents are involved in the schools and
we go from the bottom 10 to the top ten
we cannot continue to say we're going to
re-elect politicians that allow us to
continue to stay in the bottom 10 in the
nation I think person whitmer's been in
office for 20 years it's time to hold
her accountable actually it's time to
just say move on go to the private
sector see how that works for you well
it'll probably make her a lot of money
but that would be better than the the
current situation so I don't think I've
been to to Michigan I was there probably
been about five years I did a couple
shows in Grand Rapids and the crowds
were absolutely awesome but before that
I was in Detroit I went to the GM Center
over there what's the building called
the GM Center or GM that building that's
the it's the total recall building I was
very excited to be there it's a very
cool building uh but then obviously if
you go outside into Detroit it's not
good to say the least what what can
actually be done because it's been under
Democrat control for for decades I think
at this point
and think of the Optics of this she had
Barack Obama here over the weekend and
you know when you're bringing Barack
Obama in that means you need to get your
base out so she brought Barack Obama in
and took him into Detroit and he made
fun of the fact that there was crime in
the cities saying you know this is a
trump problem
it was unbelievable how glib he was
about it
and and think of the Optics of that
standing in the second most violent city
in America and saying re-elect this
person continue to have Democrats
running this state it is outrageous well
we know that Gretchen Whitmer marched
with the folks that are carrying the
science defund the police she said she
supports the spirit of defund the police
overall when you continually push to
defund the police and you don't honor
that position we are losing police we
there was a point in uh maybe a little
bit earlier in summer where newspaper
ran an article saying we've lost a cop a
day in the city of Detroit that's how
challenging it is to get to get police
to stay in their positions in Michigan
because they don't have the support of
the chief executive officer we know how
important that is we know that we can
bring that back we're not only going to
put money into our police but we're
going to make sure that everybody in the
state knows that they are supported on
it honored and respected by the Dixon
Administration was she always so far
left or I don't even know that it's far
left like so government must do
everything all the time and will control
every bit of your life or did this all
kind of burst forth when covet happened
oh she's always been
always been a progressive I mean she
came out we have her on tape as a
senator coming out and saying that she
wants to get rid of ice she wants to
abolish ice very clearly yes I want to
abolish ice she also voted against a ban
on partial birth abortion so we know
that where she's always stood in the
same place there and don't forget that
not too far a lot not too far back when
she was a state senator she wanted to
vote against right for right to work and
so she opened the doors of the Capitol
even though they were locked and they
were trying to keep the legislators safe
from from the protesters she opened the
doors to the Capitol in fact there's
even a story that she helped to open a
side window to the Capitol and let the
protesters in and then she went on tape
and and in her 2018 campaign when she
was on the debate stage we're on a news
interview she said I threw open the
doors of the Capitol and let the people
in I mean this is pretty radical when
you know the state police have it locked
down and are trying to keep the
legislators safe to open the doors and
have all these protesters come into the
capitol so this has always been who she
is she's a radical Progressive she's
also trying to shut down a pipeline in
the state of Michigan she is on board
with the and the anti-American energy
message she's been trying to shut down
the pipeline the entire time she's been
in office she has a lawsuit still out
there it would decimate the state of
Michigan it would kill our economy it
would raise prices to heat homes it's a
terrible terrible situation we have to
protect the State against these radical
Progressive policies yeah that actually
was the next question I want to ask you
because obviously with GM there and so
much of the automotive industry coming
from Michigan and Detroit uh this push
from the administration against fossil
fuels and all of this stuff I mean this
is sort of a direct assault on you guys
oh absolutely and we so we have people
in the state certainly in the businesses
manufacturing manufacturers use a lot of
energy we see that the binding
Administration wants to shut down
sources of energy Gretchen Whitmer is on
board with shutting down those sources
of energy so I've had multiple people
come to me whether they are folks that
live in the Upper Peninsula of Michigan
or manufacturers all across the state
who are saying to me can you assure us
that you will not have a Gavin Newsom
approach approach to energy because
we're considering leaving the state of
Michigan because we know Gretchen
Whitmer wants to be the most Progressive
Energy governor in the country and we've
already seen Gavin Newsom say he's
Banning gas vehicles we are deathly
afraid that that's going to happen in
the state of Michigan and I've assured
people that is not how we will manage
the state of Michigan and if you want to
make sure that you have the energy
sources that we have always had and that
we increase that you have to vote for
addiction Administration do you know
what the numbers are in terms of people
fleeing Michigan you know you don't hear
about it like Cali in New York obviously
but I'm guessing that you must have lost
a decent amount of people during covet
so many that we actually lost a
congressional seat so we were one of the
states that lost yes yes it is
significant and when I go around the
state I have multiple businesses saying
to me hey look we're building new
factories but it's not going to be in
Michigan the regulatory state is a
nightmare Gretchen whitmer's
Administration has ramped that up been
really tough on business across the
board not just covet across the board so
when I talk to our businesses they're
like
sorry but we're actually building new
facilities in Texas or we're already
moving to Indiana that's the last thing
we want is to see our businesses going
down to down South we want to make sure
that we are the place that they want to
build expand and stay and I believe that
we can do that all right so since
everyone can see you're on the tour bus
where are you headed for the last couple
days and uh I guess go ahead and make a
prediction why not huh
yeah we're all over the state so we're
going to be I'm spending a lot of time
in the next day in the southeast part of
Michigan we're going to go back over to
West Michigan we're going to travel as
much as we can to meet as many people as
possible through the state we just came
from northern Michigan so we'll be
making another loop around but honestly
I it's interesting because like I said
just the feeling on the ground when you
look at her crowds when you look at our
crowds when you look at the social media
posts it seems like this neck and neck
race is potentially going our way there
are definitely a lot of a lot of quiet
Republicans out there we have the people
that are Whispering all the time I'm
voting for you I'm voting for you so I
feel like we'll have a pretty good night
on Tuesday all right my cards are on the
table I wish you good luck Tudor and uh
I hope to talk to you soon once you're
once you're a governor how about that
that sounds like a plan thank you if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell